dead island 2 gameplay was shown off and
playstation 5 teases its new premium
controller
dead island 2 is indeed still alive
during gamescom 2022 a new trailer for
the long-awaited zombie survival game
was released with a surprise reveal that
the game is coming out february 3rd 2023
dead island 2 will feature six playable
characters one of whom is featured in
the new cinematic trailer following that
melee filled look a gameplay focused
trailer was also revealed that provided
a more detailed look at all six of the
playable protagonists as well as the
large variety of melee weapons and
firearms at your disposal when dealing
with the walking dead but games weren't
the only thing shown off at opening
night live some hardware made an
appearance as well playstation 5 is
getting a new high performance
controller called the dual sense edge
and surprise it looks a lot like the
standard dual sense controller except it
appears slightly thicker in a
playstation blog that accompanied the
announcement sony shared more details on
its pro controller it will feature
customizable controls including full
button remapping stick sensitivity and
dead zone settings and trigger dead zone
settings it has a built-in function
button to adjust settings like game
volume and chat balance and quickly swap
between your control profiles you can
change your stick caps and back buttons
with included alternatives and you'll
even be able to fully replace the stick
modules with purchasable replacements
plus it retains all the usual functions
of the dual sense like haptic feedback
and adaptive triggers the dualsense edge
will come with a usbc cable and carrying
case for holding the controller and all
of its components the case is also
designed to facilitate charging with the
cable while it's in its case these
features put it roughly on par with the
xbox elite series of controllers which
offer a premium experience for a premium
price third parties have made pro like
controllers for playstation but this
will be the first official sony device
no price or release date were given
which is unfortunate because this
controller will be great for playing war
zone 2.0 which seemingly contains that
rumored dmz mode the esrb has posted its
ratings description for call of duty war
zone 2.0 and among other things the
listing contains a reference to dmz the
ratings description specifically
mentions how players can take part in a
variety of multiplayer combat events
including battle royale blunder style
skirmishes and dmz dmz has been
something of an open secret for a while
now before this nfl players mentioned
the unannounced mode before deleting the
references to it dmz is rumored to be an
extraction-based mode inspired by escape
from tarkov leaks have described dmz as
a open world mode with a mix of battle
royale and survival game elements and
the mode has reportedly been in
development for four years it was also
rumored that dmz might be set for a
standalone release in 2023 but that is
apparently not the case hit the comments
and let us know your favorite moment
from opening night live and i'll see you
again soon